[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez je vais m'en prendre une encore
les choses
très simplement vous
[Rires]
j'espère que donc vous allez bien quand
même et on va commencer donc avec les
meilleurs moments de l'indiqué de
l'année
vous allez bien
on a rien à [__] en fait on commence
avec le numéro 10 tu vas pas faire
une petite caméra cachée très sympa oui
parce que Cyril vous êtes mais oui mais
oui Siri parce que en partant de rien
vous êtes capable de faire de très
grandes choses Cyril en témoigne ce tube
à la fois littéraire et atypique caca
mou
un titre exceptionnel que vous avez pu
voir à la maison alors pour ceux qui
s'en souviennent pas on regarde
[Musique]
voilà
il a pris quand c'est devenu un tube
numéro 1 sur toutes les plateformes et
bien caca mou était donc devenu un tube
mais dans les rues de Paris il est
encore plus puisque nous avons envoyé
des équipes oui cacao en personne est
allé dans les rues de la capitale pour
aller voir ceux qui justement produisent
ce genre de choses des cacas regardez
c'est genre incroyable regardez pour
expliquer bien parce que c'est un métier
vous avez donc été dans des toilettes
publiques dès qu'il y a un mec qui sort
des toilettes vous lui faites caca moi
donc ceux qui viennent déposer un petit
bronze voilà pour être plus poli ceux
qui viennent déposer un bronze là dans
les toilettes on est allé les choper à
la sortie ce qu'on fait un caca mou
seulement par contre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment très gênant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur C8
regarde le sport c'est moi le journal
télévisé les jeux les jeux les jeux
[Applaudissements]
très drôle ça très très drôle on passe à
la neuvième place avec qui occupé par un
chroniqueur qui a été très peu présent
cette année mais qui pourtant était le
plus efficace si je vous dis des
Américains staff là qui viennent à
machin c'est Nicolas pernico regarde
elle est magnifique
il a été blanchi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
café une année magnifique ok donc vous
voyez il a été logé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
au début de l'année on a eu un nouveau
chroniqueur qui a eu un petit bizutage
il s'appelle Nino et certains
chroniqueurs sur une idée du Grand Baba
à côté de moi en profiter de sa
crédulité pour lui faire croire que
Daniel ici présente avait couché avec
Nikos Aliagas et qu'elle était enceinte
de lui c'était incroyable c'était
magnifique on regarde
ça va
génial
n'importe quoi ils ont pas le même âge
Daniel qui est enceinte de Nico c'était
pas au courant
tu es pas au courant bien sûr elle est
enceinte de Nikos elle a apporté
en Grèce
tu vois
pas me regarde pas Daniel si Nino il
parle de Nico c'est un moment il faut
que tu partes en couille ouais genre tu
dis ouais Nico j'aimerais qu'on parle
pas de Nico ça allait très bien ce qui
s'est passé Benjamin il y a plein de
gens qui se disaient et vous avez gagné
énormément d'argent
[Rires]
il faut pas parler
t'inquiète pas je le ferai plus
pendant la pub il m'ont dit que je peux
pas dire ça
ils m'ont dit que apparemment tu as
avorté de Nikos
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ce sont des énormes Charo à votre
avis qui sont les plus grands Charo de
autant de la taille Guillaume
parce que c'est un nouveau magnéto bien
sûr que si bien sûr que si oui parce
qu'ils ont eu la bistouquette en
altitude cette année Guillaume et
Raymond
avec une copie des pépites
[Musique]
pourquoi de la guerre je pense quoi de
la guerre
de charogne
il a aucune
étiquette
hôpital qui se fout de la charité
l'abominable homme de Rungis ne sait
plus quoi faire ne sont pas ma vitesse
[Musique]
mais lorsque la marche sur les
plate-bandes de l'autre et bien ça crée
des petites frictions bien sûr
les invités Guillaume s'est rabattu sur
le terrain à domicile et à tenter le
coup avec Béatrice
[Musique]
je pense que
Bigot
je voulais te parler bonne émission
sur le plateau en général merci
[Applaudissements]
au numéro 4 Cyril avec quelqu'un que
vous adorez c'est un peu votre chouchou
si je vous dis chevelure ondulée et
trône en bronze donc c'est Bertrand
Deckers c'est votre chouchou il a oublié
il est venu un jour ici il a oublié de
se coiffer et les invités c'était
extraordinaire Bertrand Descartes numéro
[Musique]
alors très beau tu es beau vous dites ça
tous les gens que vous l'avez même pas
vu alors que pourtant les invités eux
l'ont bien vu
alors passons
à ces événements est remise en cause sur
le sport
avec la famille royale
et oui coupe de cheveux regardez-moi ça
surtout les invités étaient choqués
Tarek Boudali Julien routier aussi
ce soir
tu dormais bah non je descends du train
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y en a un qui malgré ses 50 ans
télévision on a toujours pas compris
qu'il était filmé c'est Bernard Montiel
à chaque fois qu'on reçoit des invités
au look atypique ou au tarpée éclectique
vous allez comprendre pourquoi Bernard
Montiel fait des têtes très bizarre
c'est les têtes de la armentier numéro 3
[Musique]
et des éléments je fais rien
d'autre blogueur Jeremstar à son nom est
alors entaché dans un sombre scandale le
Jeremstar game
qui Bernard est un sacré coquinou la
preuve avec notre invité on forme
généreuse
Bernard a été bail par cette magnifique
reprise de Tina Turner regardez
[Musique]
un petit souci avec les hommes à barbe
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
sur Daniel c'était tatie Daniel mais il
a vraiment un souci avec les hommes à
barres regardez merci les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
qui a simulé sa mort c'est une histoire
de fou
alors profite pour remercier tous les
intervenants qui viennent à tous les
jours de ici on se rencontrer qui sont
nuls on a vu à Nice aussi on a vu le
monsieur là que là qui est très très
sympa avec la barbe aussi on a vu tout
le monde voilà donc tous ceux qui
viennent sur le plateau merci à eux de
venir voilà merci à eux et merci à eux
de venir témoigner merci beaucoup eh ben
puisqu'on parle des tetés des réactions
Cyril on passe au numéro 2 et à chaque
fois qu'elle est venue sur un plateau
faire
des réactions magnifiques des têtes
magnifiques à chaque fois c'est
exceptionnel c'est le numéro 2 les totés
d'affinateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
à vous alors
elle est là avec Dylan ils sont là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le nom du
[Applaudissements]
bravo bravo pour le live
nous avons réalisé quelque chose
chanter sur une garde dans une gare sans
répétition mais juste pour vous et
public et pour réaliser le rêve
je me mets où là très bien
mais toi là fais attention quand même ça
va mais j'ai pas du tout aimé pourquoi
vous faites une gueule de vacances
[Rires]
j'ai un truc à te donner parce que je
vais oublier tiens c'est un cadeau pour
toi
[Musique]
pour mettre dans la voiture
je veux qu'elle soit à toutes les
émissions
l'année prochaine
bah écoute j'ai trouvé du boulot alors
je commence le 10 juillet j'ai un
contrat de 6 mois j'ai trouvé du boulot
si tu peux venir quelques fois ce sera
avec plaisir ouais tu travailles de quoi
du lundi au vendredi du lundi au
vendredi j'ai pas encore les horaires
mais en tout cas je sais que je commence
le 10 juillet et c'est un contrat de 6
mois service administratif mais secret
défense oh
[__]
est-ce que tu es contente de la surprise
que Cyril est celui que tu as fait de
chanter chaîne en direct dans la gare
c'était quand même ton fantasme
franchement franchement c'était trop
cool franchement c'était une une belle
expérience c'était vraiment super
franchement on sortait dans la gare et
tout en plus il y avait des clients
heureusement qu'ils sont pas venus me
demander des renseignements parce que là
je pouvais pas leur donner les numéros
de train là c'était compliqué
il doit y aller tu vas tu peux prendre
Dylan avec toi
mais je veux vraiment que tu viennes
l'année prochaine un peu avec nous c'est
super quand tu as été chroniqueur
attends je vais où viens avec moi ok
j'arrive merci à vous deux merci
monsieur et enfin le numéro 1 avant de
repartir Cyril avant de repartir c'est
ma séquence notre séquence préférée de
l'année comment vous faites Cyril je
sais c'est ma préférée comment vous
faites juste quand quelqu'un vient vous
voir que ce soit vos collègues vos amis
etc c'est pas vrai je l'adore
c'est le sortez-moi de là de l'année
vous allez voir il cherche une étude
secours à tout prix c'est notre numéro 1
c'est l'extrait c'est la pépite de
l'année
[Musique]
il a mordu un serpent
rapidement c'est ça
[Musique]
et plus la conversation avance plus
série il est passionné ah oui voilà
parce qu'après le rongeur en fait
s'attaque au reptile
comme dans la salive des rongeurs il y a
une espèce d'anesthésiant le reptile a
les mythe vont même pas compte qu'ils
seront ranger ça peut faire de gros gros
dégâts
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant oui
à la tête de Cyril on le voit sauf qu'on
va pas se mentir Cyril recherche un trou
d'air
quand sur l'émission il y avait des fois
des trucs
avec plaisir avec plaisir chez Cyril
sachet-le ça veut dire
à côté de la porte d'Orléans
[Musique]
merci beaucoup je vais venir mon chéri
avec plaisir ouais on va pas reprendre
la discussion mais t'inquiète pas je
vais revenir
merci beaucoup pour cette saison et
merci à tous merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]